hello welcome back let's get you more on
the ukraine situation the russian
advance into its territory kharkiv in
the east is the focus of fighting today
ukraine's second biggest city a gas
pipeline was hit by missiles in the
early hours and one british intelligence
assessment says there has been an
intensive exchange of rocket artillery
meanwhile thousands of people are trying
to leave the country we're joined now by
thomas jones the british national he's
at the polish border near a small town
called rusev hi there good to see you
today what's the situation there where
you are at the moment is there a big
attempt to get out
there is um we're in a small town called
cruise ship which is in the libiv region
another town closes called yavariv
i've been here since
one o'clock
yesterday and now it's coming up to 12
o'clock midday here so i've been about
23 hours we've moved
i think three kilometers in that time
and we've got another two and a half to
get to the border crossing
so a long process for you and so many
yeah there's a lot of people here i mean
um tailbacks are incredible uh people
walking around
um you know there's their local people
have been
last night i noticed young boys were
giving water to
people who had children in cars
offering to warm milk up
we could charge batteries at the local
local shop and things like that so
it's it's pretty busy and
quite saddening i'd have to say
a lot of people are bringing their wives
to the border post
to drop them off as you may know that
men aged from 18 to 60 are not allowed
to leave the country so you're seeing a
lot of people come in with children and
then men
walking out looking really sad
and what does that do to you when you
see that
um it hits home
regarding war i mean you know it's a
part of war you know we think tanks guns
bombs but then there's this other part
which is on the human part and uh these
people are scared um their husbands are
scared for them the children really
don't know what's going on
um it's a mess
it's it's and it's
heart-wrenchingly horrible
could you have foreseen yourself in this
position a few days ago so many people
wanting to stay put
where they were of course
i didn't foresee myself being in this
situation um for reasons i spoke to you
the other time but uh right now excuse
me the car's moving because we've got to
kind of
move ahead of the queue
um
i could never foresee myself in such a
situation and i wouldn't wish this on
anyone
um
it really hits home when you're in this
kind of situation
what's it been like living in ukraine
and how's the situation changed
okay well i've been living here now this
is my seventh year and you know i love
this country i feel bad even about
leaving um you have to take my wife to
safety uh you know to think of my family
luckily for me you know i can come and
go as i please
this is where i feel bad um because i
see so many guys here that count um and
that is really hard i have some very
solid ukrainian friendships um and
i just feel guilty right now
about this
of course i have to think about myself
about my family but the guilt is there
and how has it changed in recent weeks
in the last week it's just changed it's
come from night and day
um kiev is is uh is completely changed i
know people on the ground in kiev that
have uh joined their local uh you know
volunteer forces and um you know things
are ugly down there a lot of people that
are taking arms are very inexperienced
but they have heart they don't want
they don't want this
so you know i think um
it's going to be very messy on both
sides but
exceptionally for people that have no
experience
what do you feel about the resistance or
obviously russian troops are closing in
on kiev but they're not there yet and
that is down to
the aggression
the resistance shown by ukrainians and
others
they're strong they are strong and i
think in the last six seven years the
military has become much better
they perform well
they do their duties well they're very
good tactically i've seen um they've had
training from nato uh nato troops canada
england america so
they're prepared this time round
but you know for what's uh against them
they're doing very well
and what does it mean to you just
turning your back on a country that you
where you've lived for many years and
love
okay i wouldn't say i'm turning my back
on the country um i can't do anything i
can't take take up arms um if i could i
would consider it
but i think i can do a lot more um
for ukraine
via
by the media by the press um helping get
donations charity organizations things
like this which i'm quite good at doing
so
you know everybody has their heart to
play it's a shame i can't stay here it's
dangerous um
if things de-escalate of course i'll be
back as soon as i can
what kind of reception finally do you
think you'll get in poland let's face it
most people that's where most people are
are trying to go isn't it there are
several neighboring countries but a huge
influx of majority of people heading
west okay well
i'm not in the category of a ukrainian
fleeing um from from ukraine so i think
that the ukrainians and the whole will
get a very good reception there are
things in place food
medication accommodation and care um
ukraine and poland have a very strong
bond um and poland i think was the first
country to say that it would accept
refugees
so i think they'll get a very good
reception um
and i think they'll be taken well care
of
all right well we wish you all the best
thank you for joining us thomas jones
thank you